hello everyone welcome to today's live
broadcast cholesterol treatment
guidelines controversies and youth in
clinical practice presented by dr.
michael wacha we are excited to bring
you this educational web seminar
presented by Lambert's the leading
social media and networking site for
science professionals for more
information please visit us at
www.americanoutback.net located in lower
left of the presentation window type
your question into the box that appears
on the screen will answer as many
questions as we have time for at the end
of the presentation also please note
that you will be viewing the
presentation in the slide window to
enlarge this window just click on the
screen icon located in the lower right
finally if you have trouble seeing or
hearing the presentation please let us
know by clicking on the support button
at the top right of the presentation
window or you can use the Q&A button to
let us know that you're having a problem
this webinar has been approved for
continuing educational credits please
click on the seat at the bottom left
corner and follow the process to receive
your credit I'd now like to get right to
introduce introducing dr. Michael Rocco
Michael is the medical director of
cardiac rehabilitation and stress
testing section of preventive cardiology
and a staff cardiologist section of
clinical cardiology and preventive
cardiology in the Roberts and Suzanne
Tomczyk department of cardiovascular
medicine he also holds an appointment in
the section of nuclear Caron cardiology
in the department of molecular
functional imaging his board-certified
in internal medicine cardiology and
nuclear cardiology dr. Rocco has a
special interest in clinical cardiology
stress testing and cardiac
rehabilitation coronary artery disease
cardiac catheterization and the
treatment of lipid disorders
dr. Rocco did his undergraduate work at
Georgetown University in Washington DC
he received his medical degree from Duke
University Medical Center in Durham
North Carolina
he took his clinical training internship
and residency at Brigham and Women's
Hospital in Boston he became a research
clinical fellow and cardiology at
Brigham and Women's Hospital and at
Harvard Medical School dr. Rocco
completed the Henry J Kaiser fellowship
program at Harvard University Boston
where he trained in epidemiology
biostatistics and clinical study design
and will now turn the presentation over
to dr. Rocco Thank You Brenda and thank
you everyone for attending today I'd
like to talk about the cholesterol
treatment guidelines they've now been
available for approximately two years
but they still are a source of some
discussion and controversy so I wanted
to review them but also highlight some
of the strengths and weaknesses how it
may be incorporated into the practice of
our patients and then where it might be
going and why there might be need for
some changes in the future now if we
look at the evolution of guidelines
these go back to 1988 with the first
adult treatment panel guidelines
it wasn't until 2001 that an emphasis on
LDL cholesterol management particularly
with statins was emphasized particularly
in the setting of a number of landmark
clinical trials with statins such as 4s
and West of Scotland and care etc in
2004 there was an update that tried to
incorporate some newer data with really
some recommendations to be more
aggressive with treatment in high-risk
patients and to institute treatment
earlier in high-risk patients and then
this was confirmed in HACC updates in
2006 and 2011 but it really wasn't until
12 years later that we have a complete
new set of guidelines and those are the
HACC guidelines were going to review
today which built upon further clinical
trials now we just start with a question
now this is a 56 year old overweight
male with type 2 diabetes
at Forman a nonsmoker with hypertension
controlled on an ACE inhibitor a family
history of diabetes and myocardial
infarction his sedentary and has
claudication symptoms with an abnormal
ABI and you can see his lipid panel
there his LDL triglycerides total and
non HDL cholesterol are elevated with a
low HDL with a elevated april-b
LDL particle number and a1c of 7.3 so
the question is based on current
guidelines goals for therapy and this
patient should be one of the five
following LDL goals of less than 70 and
100 and number one and two and a Kobe
goal of less than 80 and LDL particle
number of less than 1,000 or statin
therapy for LDL reduction of greater
than fifty percent now it's actually
somewhat of a trick question I don't I
know we don't have an audience response
mechanism but actually all of these have
been recommended as appropriate goals
for treatment in a high-risk patient
such as this but if the question was
based on the new accha guidelines the
answer would be number five statin
therapy for an LDL reduction so this
represents sort of the major paradigm
shift in the new guidelines and one of
the reasons for some controversy so we
can understand where these come by
reviewing the reasons why the or the the
goals that the people were charged with
who wrote the guidelines so these were
sort of started in 2008 convened by
NHLBI and transitioned to the ACCA h.a
in 2013 for finalization dissemination
and implementation but the main charge
of the guidelines was to come up with an
evidence-based recommendation for
cholesterol-lowering drug therapies that
were shown to significantly reduce
atherosclerosis cure disease endpoints
and the base this on assists systematic
review of randomized controlled trials
and meta-analysis of these types of
trials and try to minimize observational
at a an expert opinion questions that
were charged to address or whether LDL
or non HDL goals both for primary and
secondary prevention were supported by
the current clinical trial data and
emphasize the benefits of event
reduction relative to side effects of
statin and non statin therapy from this
they constructed evidence statements
that were synthesized into clinical
recommendations with levels of strength
according to the NHLBI standards or the
accha classifications that we are which
we are familiar with now there's also a
risk assessment group that was charged
with trying to come up with a data set
that was norm more modern to develop a
predictive tool particularly for primary
prevention patients that could help
minimize some of the complicated with
the Framingham risk calculator which has
sort of been the core of the ATP 3 a
guideline risk calculator so there are
some good and some bad issues here so
what are the good well I think the
emphasis on evidence-based management
and using clinical trials forth for the
basis of the statements is a good thing
to do we want to try to approach our
patients and use treatments that have
been proven to be beneficial the
emphasis that statin therapy should be
the primary therapy and titrating to
maximally effective doses also makes a
lot of sense and there's a lot of
clinical data demonstrating incremental
benefits with more potent statin therapy
and high-risk patients they also
critically reviewed and expanded safety
recommendations they did a fairly
thorough review of the current clinical
trial database which i think is a good
source for us and they also recognize
that there's a lot of unknown data and
implemented a potential mechanism for
early review of new data and earlier
revisions when new data is available
however emphasis on evidence-based
clinical trials is also one of the bad
points because this is a randomized
trials are
controlled restricted groups oftenly
often and there are outliers that may
not be covered by these clinical trials
it also eliminated lipid goals for
therapy which has been rooted in our
practice standards for a long time and
no recommendations are very little
recommendations for treating beyond LDL
cholesterol and statin therapy with a
major D emphasis of non statin therapy
and this represented a marked change in
our established prior recommendations
without any attempt to harmonize with
the previous guidelines which I think
caused a lot of confusion and concern
and then there was the new risk
calculator which was put out there
without prior publication or pair review
which raised a fair amount of ire and
confusion as well so that having been
said let's really review what the
guidelines tell us the number one
emphasis was on healthy lifestyle
as the foundation for cardiovascular
risk reduction and these guidelines were
published simultaneously with
recommendations for risk assessment
obesity management and lifestyle non
pharmacologic management but number two
really highlights the the main statement
of the guidelines and that is that they
identified four groups for which there
was strong evidence that statin therapy
when implemented would substantially
reduce adverse cardiovascular endpoints
and this included individuals with
clinical atherosclerosis ease those with
a primary elevation of LDL before
treatment of greater than 190 to try to
identify simply familial
hypercholesterolemia patients diabetic
patients and then those patients without
any of the above that had a estimated
risk of a hard cardiovascular endpoint
of greater than seven and a half percent
over ten years they did recognize that
other groups might benefit but the
evidence was less strong a corollary to
this was that they felt that evidence
was inadequate from clinical trials to
supports specific LDL or non HDL goals
for therapy and therefore treatment
should be focused primarily on intensity
get statin using either a moderate or
high intensity statin which were the
doses that were proven to be beneficial
in clinical trials they also introduced
a new pooled cohort equation that added
stroke to the endpoints to calculate
ten-year but also lifetime risk of an
event occurring to help in the
management of primary prevention on
diabetic patients they did emphasize
though that clinician patient discussion
was prominently important particularly
when initiating statin therapy in
primary prevention patients a lot of
time was spent identifying the safety
risks both of statins and also of non
stanton therapies but the bottom line
was they felt statins had an acceptable
margin of safety when used in selected
properly selected individuals and here
they went outside of their their goals
of randomized trials and this is
primarily based on expert opinion in
terms of how to manage adverse effects
such as satin intolerance how to address
some of the issues of increased diabetes
risk and cognitive issues there was
reduced emphasis on on statin therapies
although it is mentioned that they may
be considered in selected individuals
and expert opinion was also offered on
how to use certain biomarkers and
non-invasive testing for subclinical
disease as a way to further risk
stratify patients and then they added a
pathway for future updates to the
guidelines so this is just a schematic
of the treatment groups here represented
are the first three groups the clinical
disease the LDL greater than 190 and the
diabetic population and as you can see
in the green boxes in the majority of
these patients it's recommended to use a
high intensity statin by that they mean
a statin that can lower LDL cholesterol
by 50 percent or more
pretty much limiting up to 40 to 80
milligrams of a torva statin or 20 to 40
milligrams of rasuu the statin in
individuals that are older over 75 or
have a profile that might put them at
higher risk for side effects and higher
doses of statins a moderate intensity
stat
so that would be a statin which can
lower LDL cholesterol is between 30 and
50% in the diabetic population in yellow
high-intensity statins are recommended
for those that have a 10-year risk of
seven-and-a-half percent or greater and
in reality in the diabetic over 40 years
with one risk factor typically most of
those patients would have a risk of
greater than seven and a half percent so
the majority of patients with diabetes
that we care for that often are coupled
with other risk factors would fall into
this high-intensity group others would
be treated with a moderate intensity
statin the most controversial area has
been in those individuals that fall into
a primary prevention group so have none
of the above
but in the in the green squares those
individuals that have a seven and a half
percent 10-year risk based on the pool
[ __ ]
pool cohort calculator would be
candidates for moderate or high
intensity statins
they also recommend it to the right and
yellow based on meta-analysis that have
shown even individuals that fall into a
five to seven and a half percent risk
have been shown to benefit with a
similar relative risk reduction with
satin therapies should be considered if
there are other factors that suggest
these patients may be in higher risk
there are a number of patients that fall
outside of these four groups so the
younger or older diabetics the younger
or older primary prevention patients and
patients with a 10-year risk of less
than 5% but even these patients are
highlighted as ones that might be based
on individual assessment and other risk
marker assessments candidates to
consider therapies monitoring of LDL
cholesterol was recommended primarily to
assess adherence to therapy but not
specifically to assess for a goal for
treatment that a fasting lipid profile
should be used that routine monitoring
of liver function studies or spend CPK's
were downgraded unless symptomatic if
they address the issue of diabetes and
the rich
of diabetes with statins but overall
felt that and selected appropriately
selected patients the benefits of
statins outweighed the small risk of
diabetes development that these patients
should just be followed and screened
with more emphasis on healthy lifestyle
intervention in these high-risk patients
so a number of controversies though came
out very quickly and I wanted to address
some of those some of these these
controversies actually with careful
reading of the guidelines and going
deeper than just the summary have been
addressed with within the guidelines but
there are others that still exist and I
think will continue to be problems for
some people but I want to first focus on
number one the lack of recommendations
for target's lipid goals again they look
for percent reduction not specific lipid
goals and follow-up for adherence again
not to see if goals are achieved but
linked to this so that there are a few
recommendations for what to do with non
statin or add-on therapy particularly in
that high-risk subgroup of patients that
are on statins but have metabolic
dislocate emia so if you look at the
statements from the guidelines there are
no recommendations for but they also say
they have no recommendations
specifically against LDL or non HDL
targets predominantly because the goal
was evidence-based recommendations and
no randomized trials were ever designed
to look at a titration strategy to
specific goals also they said there are
some potential problems if you adopt a
treat to target strategy only number one
that the clinical trial data is not
there to tell us what the most
appropriate targets should be in these
patients are there targets that might be
too low in terms of complications or
side effects for example also when we're
predominantly talking about adding
additional therapies to statin therapies
since there is very little in terms of
randomized control trials there's an
unknown
benefit in terms of atherosclerosis when
weighed against additional adverse
effects from multi drug therapeutic
regimens conversely they also said that
if you treat just based on a target you
could potentially under treat some
patients and put them on suboptimal dose
as a sentence for example quitting
someone with an LDL cholesterol that's
relatively low on a low dose of a less
potent statin like pravastatin to
achieve a goal may actually be under
treating that patient since clinical
trials have shown that higher dose
statins are beneficial even in high-risk
patients with quote normal LDL
cholesterol and if you're adding other
drugs where there's concerns about drug
drug interactions and clinical practice
there might be a tendency not to use
higher intensity statins to prevent drug
drug interactions if other drugs are
added so I think the emphasis of
intensive statin therapy and to use the
highest tolerated dose with a D emphasis
on non Staton therapies particularly as
early therapies in this patients does
make sense for the majority of high-risk
patients however the lack of goals for
achieved effect really seems to go
against our understanding of the linear
relationship between cholesterol levels
and disease risk and a lot of
observational data it ignores the
concept that even patients on statin
therapy still have a substantial
residual risk and that other therapies
may further address that risk and again
little recommendations for managing this
metabolic disappeared emia so the
argument of why to treat to lower LDL
targets and use a target for therapy is
based on a number of observations we
know that newborns unless they have a
familial genetic hypercholesterolemia
really of LDL cholesterol is typically
in the 30s during the first year of life
and even when saturated fat is
introduced into the diet may double into
the 50 to
60 range and many people feel that an
LDL between 50 to 70 milligrams per
deciliter is really a reasonable
physiologic level to have throughout
life in terms of risks of vascular
disease we know that lower is better
when we compare the effects of a more
potent statin to a less potent statin
unfortunately there's less data looking
at further additional lowering of LDL
cholesterol with non statin therapies
and the question still remains whether
this will make a difference although
there is a lot of observational data
meta analyses of clinical trials which
do seem to support that lower levels of
LDL cholesterol achieved with therapies
are better so this is just an example on
the top or primary prevention and
secondary prevention statin trials
really showing this log linear
relationship between LDL cholesterol
achieved in the trials and coronary
heart disease event reduction and this
log-linear effect seems to be present
even down to LDL cholesterol as well
below 70 and in the lower panel when
we're also looking at non statin
therapies such as ileal exclusion hence
of dietary therapies niacin for example
there is still this relationship between
cholesterol lowering and coronary heart
disease event lowering if we look at
some of the statin trials that compared
higher intensity doses to lower
intensity statins the TMT trial on the
top looked at 10 versus 80 milligrams of
a torva statin but when achieved LDLs
were grouped into quartiles there was a
ramp reduction in major cardiovascular
events as the LDL drop even below 64
milligrams per deciliter and in the
pruvit trial where 40 milligrams of a
tour of a statin was compared to 18
grams Provost Aten was compared to 80
milligrams of atorvastatin you can see
in this quartile analysis that even with
LDL cholesterol is below 40 milligrams
per deciliter there tends still to be a
trend toward reducing event rate so with
statin therapies it has been
demonstrated that lower does does appear
to be better I think that's one of the
rationales for optimizing statin therapy
to high intensity doses in patients but
the question of further reducing LDL
cholesterol with other therapies or
modifying other lipid parameters has
been harder to prove in the clinical
trials and I think this affected to a
great extent the recommendations and
statements and the guidelines so here if
we look at trials such as a cord with
phenol fibrate aim high and thrive with
niacin added to adequate statin therapy
some investigational studies with the
cholesterol ester transfer protein
trials with tour set repetitive
anisotropy boniva cetra Pibb in all of
these trials some affecting LDL some
predominantly affecting triglycerides
and or HDL cholesterol none of them in
general populations have shown very
promising results in fact they've been
negative studies or adverse studies the
accelerate trial right here is listed as
ongoing but I haven't updated this slide
but two weeks ago this study was also
stopped for futility and this is a drug
that raises HDL cholesterol well above a
hundred percent and lowers LDL
cholesterol 30 to 40 percent so it
emphasizes the concern that the the
writers of the guidelines had and that
not all drugs that necessarily make the
numbers look better necessarily make
people do better and so we should have
some caution about just treating two
targets with therapies without proof it
wasn't until recently that we have an
LDL predominantly LDL modifying drug
acetamide which was studied in the
improvement trial and a high-risk group
of PO
coronary syndrome patients where Zed
amide was added to adequate simvastatin
therapy which did show a modest but
significant 2% absolute reduction over
time so this is one of the first studies
which begins to highlight that that
other modifying therapies on top of
adequate statins may add additional
benefit and that treating to lower
targets are justifiable this is just
looking at the seven-year follow-up on
the top and the improve at trial about
1,800 18,000 patients LDLs in the
placebo group of 70 that dropped to
about 54 and that was associated with a
2 plus 2 percent absolute risk reduction
and if we look at some data from
meta-analysis from the CCS CT T studies
a line that was developed based on
reduction in a vent rate relative to the
amount of reduction in LDL cholesterol
on the right the statin versus placebo
trials in the middle statin high dose
versus low dose and then if in the
orange triangle we add the improve-it
trial data it does seem to fit along the
same curve with the additional
reductions of about 16mm milligrams per
deciliter so there is some data that's
coming out now that treating beyond
statin therapy and particularly to low
LDL goals adds incremental benefit and
now we have available two very potent
LDL lowering drugs the pcsk9 inhibitors
this is just some data presented at the
ACC this year looking at a LaRocca map
in the Odyssey trials in the upper panel
this is just the percent reduction
sustained out to seventy eight weeks of
greater than 50% reduction in LDL
cholesterol this is identical to the
reduction that was seen in the Osler
studies with Eva locum AB
on the lower panel this is an attempt to
look at early event reduction in the
Osler trial but again a similar
reduction of about 50% was noted in the
Odyssey long term trial now these
studies were not designed prospectively
to look at outcomes the OWSLA trial for
example was randomized but not blinded
open-label so we have to look at this
data with a grain of salt there were a
small number of event rates but at least
it suggests that we're going in the
right direction with aggressively
lowering LDL cholesterol further in
high-risk individuals so I think these
studies which hopefully will be
available the end of 2017 in 2018 these
are long term randomized control outcome
trials in over 60,000 individuals I
think will address well some of the
questions and concerns that people have
in terms of further reduction but for
now we have to extrapolate and the only
available study is the improve at trial
but I think more importantly in the
guidelines and I think one
disappointment was that there was little
guidance of what to do with triglyceride
and HDL management and further
management and the subgroup of patients
with metabolic this lipid emia which we
know represents a high risk patient I
realize that there's not a lot of an
randomised trials but this is one area I
think where expert opinion might have
offered some guidance in management if
we look at a meta-analysis of over 60
trials we can see that triglycerides
above 200 even when controlling for HDL
and LDL cholesterol and other risk
factors is associated with a 20 to 25
percent increased risk of CVD mortality
and all cause mortality and if we look
below in the United States overall about
16% of the population 20% of men and 13
percent of women have triglycerides that
are above 200 so it's not a trivial
problem
and while I understand and men
trials that have been done this is a
slide of a number of trials looking at
fibrates niacin such as named I trial
and high doses of fish oil is in the
jelous trial there was inconsistent
results in terms of reduction in
endpoints when all of these studies were
analyzed looking at the subgroup of
patients that are most likely to benefit
from these modifications so those
patients that have high triglycerides
and/or low HDL cholesterol or metabolic
pattern or diabetes in these sub
analyses the benefits in terms of
primary endpoint of composite
cardiovascular adverse events was
actually statistically significant in
these sub analyses so it does suggest
even though we don't have specific
randomized controlled trials in these
subgroups that meta that sub analyses of
these trials support further
intervention in this high-risk
population of patients that have
persistent the elevated triglycerides
above 200 and low HDL there are two
ongoing studies with fish oil
preparations at high doses the strength
trial being one of them for example
where patients are being identified
based on high risk clinically with
triglycerides above 180 to 200 and HDLs
below 42 to 45 in men and women so
hopefully clinical trials that are
really highlighting aggressive therapy
in the groups of patients that are most
able to benefit will also show down the
road some additional benefit and this
may be important in further
modifications of the guidelines and
while LDL goals have also been
restricted non HDL goals have also been
taken out of the equation in the new
guidelines but this is something that we
know may be important in terms of not
only identifying risk but particularly
risk in patients on treatment so if we
look at this slide and individuals in
the third line down with LDL cholesterol
therapy of less than 100 elevated non
HDL cholesterol above 130 is a strong
marker for future risk with a hazard
ratio of 1.3 to so non HDL cholesterol
still is an important independent
predictor of risk particularly on
therapy would treating to lower non HDL
cholesterol goals be beneficial
again not specifically addressed in
clinical trials and left out of the
guidelines so moving on to a second
controversy and that being the risk
calculator for primary prevention
decisions in terms of treatment many
people criticized this because it was
just put out there without review but
there were also criticisms based on the
actual utility of this to identify
correctly risk in patients now I think
it was a noble goal people understood
that the Framingham risk study had its
limitations in terms of the cohort that
was studied and it was identified many
years ago that this risk calculator over
assess risk in many populations they
elected to expand the end point to
include stroke which i think is
reasonable and keeping up with the
European and Canadian endpoint in the
guidelines and they tried to see cohorts
which were more representative of a more
modern United States population wanting
to add other racial diversity to the
equations but at least consider
additions of african-americans to the
equations for risk prediction so what
they came up with was a tool which if
you look at the factors in the tool not
very different from the ATP risk
calculator other than the addition of
african-american or white to to the
categories and they use the population
fairly evenly distributed among men
and women with a representative
african-american population of patients
now soon after this came out it was
criticized by a number of people Paul
Richard from Boston published a patient
paper very quickly and a graph from that
paper is seen on this slide indicating
that there could be substantial
overestimation of risk applying this cap
this calculator anywhere from sixty
seven to one hundred and fifty percent
and they applied the calculation to the
woman's health and the physicians health
study and the women's health initiative
observational cohort they criticized it
even though this was an attempt to be
more modern it was still based on older
data and that using a lower cutoff of
seven and a half percent rather than 10
percent 10-year risk that the number of
Americans eligible for treatment would
increase by about 13 million so 56
million Americans would be eligible and
potentially then if we're over essing
risk overestimating risk exposing
patients needlessly to the potential
side-effects of statin therapies now the
ACCAC countered saying well you know the
Women's Health Study and the physician
Health Study are not necessarily
representative of the United States
population and healthy volunteer
randomized control trial subjects are
often very different than than an
unselected population of patients and so
this is not necessarily a representative
group number one in addition a lot of
the risk factors in these studies were
self-reported in ranges rather than
direct measurements there was incomplete
event capture and there was no way to
account for downstream therapies and
over time therapeutic recommendations
changed and they thought it was not
surprising that looking at these
databases that there would be an over
estimate and in fact when the calculator
was applied to the database from the
regards trial I'll be at a five-year
data that was extrapolated out to ten
years they did report that looking at
different sub levels of red
there was pretty good concordance until
you get to the highest risk group also
when compared to the score trial from
Europe the accha calculator correlated
pretty well with the score European
scores identification of high-risk
patients and lastly since we're using
these calculators to try to identify
patients who would benefit from statin
therapy a corollary that being those
that already have preclinical
cardiovascular disease such as
atherosclerosis when a study was done
examining CT angiogram of the coronary
arteries in over three thousand and
patients it found that the accha
guidelines from two thousand thousand
thirteen calculators compared to the old
eighty p3 calculator was much better at
identifying those patients that had
heavy plaque burdens and therefore more
appropriate for statin therapy by ninety
two percent versus fifty three percent
so we can argue both ways but I think
the important thing to recognize is that
no calculator is perfect these are based
on certain populations and then applied
to different populations also therapies
are changing between the time calculator
databases are collected and they are
applied then to individual patients the
annals published a paper in 2015
comparing different calculators they
looked at the Framingham risk coronary
heart disease calculator the initial one
their modifications to include and
expand to other cardiovascular diseases
the 18 P 3 modification of the
Framingham risk score for the guidelines
in 2001 the HACC 2013 score and then the
Reynolds score which is a little
different than all of them in that they
did incorporate family history and
inflammatory marker of CRP and this is a
busy slide but as you can see the
the line represents perfect concordance
and just a quick glance indicates that
most of these calculators and men and
three out of the five and women do
overestimate risk the Reynolds score
seeming to be about the best in men and
the Framingham cardiovascular disease
extended score in women so I think it's
important to recognize that many of
these scores do overestimate and in fact
if we look at the ATP 3 calculator in
men it tended to overestimate by a
hundred and fifty four percent compared
to 86 percent in the new ATP 3 2013
calculator and in women both of these
calculators do overestimate risk as well
so at least in men this calculator which
was criticized because of over
estimation was actually somewhat better
than what we had been using to in the
ten years preceding so in terms of risk
scores it's very important you want an
accurate cardiac estimation because it's
essential in trying to balance at an
individual patient the risks of therapy
against the preventive benefits an
overestimation can certainly expose
lower risk patients unnecessarily to the
risk of a therapy in this case statin
therapies and it has implications from a
public health standpoint in terms of
adverse events and cost so I think we
need to look at these calculators only
as a starting point for clinicians
really to begin discussions of the risks
and benefits of treatments not only a
statin therapy but the importance of
focusing on management of other risk
factors and lifestyle rather than there
being a mandate to write a prescription
for a statin therapy and in fact if you
read the guidelines the authors
themselves advocate that the risk of
over seven and a half percent should not
result in necessarily starting a drug
but commencing the conversation with the
patient on how best to manage
with the possibility of using a statin
therapy as one of those therapeutic
interventions lastly I want to just
focus on the concern about potentially
under treating some patients and over
treating others and I think if you look
into the guidelines you'll see that
there are mechanisms that we can use in
clinical practice to address these
outlying patients so the younger older
individuals those patients that that are
young with a strong family history and
elevated LDL those with insufficient
response to therapy so let's look at
this pace patient a 36 year old male of
Indian descent strong family history
nonsmoker without risk factors blood
pressure controlled BMI of 25 with the
lipid profile on the right now the fact
that he's under 40 the risk calculator
from the guidelines wouldn't even apply
and even four years later if we applied
the calculator with identical numbers
his 10 year risk would be 3.1 percent
for an adverse event and 50 percent
lifetime risk so assuming his medical
history remained unchanged he would have
to be 51 before he crossed that cut
point of seven and a half percent so do
the guidelines suggest then that we
don't treat this individual and that we
focus on lifestyle interventions and
until he's over 50 well actually they do
address this in the guideline so they
recommend specifically that in adults
with LDLs less than 190 do not fit into
another statin benefit group or whom
after quantitative risk assessment
treatment decision is uncertain
additional factors may be used to try to
reassess risk and make a judgment about
the benefits and risk reduction versus
side-effects and in treating these
patients and the factors to consider
include an LDL greater than 160 family
history of the disease and males less
than 55 and females less than 65
elevated inflammatory marker of a CRP
greater than or equal to 2 and elevated
coronary calcium score a B is of less
than 0.9 or a high lifetime risk
and in the individual we just looked at
with an LDL of over 160 family history
elevated CRP and high lifetime risk it's
a patient that falls outside of those
boundaries that you would certainly have
a discussion with the patient about the
benefits of instituting statin therapy
and it would be supported by the
guidelines conversely we have a patient
here who is 47 no family history
hypertension but controlled on
hydrochlorothiazide no history of
diabetes a nonsmoker elevated BMI and
sedentary his 10 year risk is seven
point six percent but he has an LDL
cholesterol of 95 triglycerides of 150
normal glucose CRP borderline at 1.9 so
is this a patient that you would start a
statin on and the guidelines tell us
that this is necessary
well again the guidelines say that this
is a starting point for discussion we
can use the same factors that we use to
assess greater risks to try to reassess
lower risk so he does not have an
elevated CRP or lipoprotein a he does
not have a family history his lifetime
risk is not significantly high although
not reported here and as LDL is low and
this is a patient that you might rightly
focus on lifestyle issues to work on the
weight and the exercise and hold off on
initiating a staff another group is a
group with insufficient response so here
we have a 52 year old african-american
with atherosclerosis being managed
medically controlled hypertension good
control of diabetes a nonsmoker
overweight and sedentary with this lipid
panel now he falls into a high-risk
group with diabetes and overt
cardiovascular disease so he started on
80 milligrams of atorvastatin a high
intensity statin met with a nutritionist
for dietary issues and started a walking
program and then he has a lipid panel to
assess his compliance not necessarily
goals his LDL is down to 101 so less
than 50% reduction so he's already on
maximal intensity statins based on the
guidelines is this
as far as we go or are there
recommendations that we could consider
additional therapies in this patient
again there are individuals not this
particular patient who is taking his
medications but has a less than optimal
response but we're seeing more and more
patients that are not on statins are
limiting the maximum dose of statins
because of side-effects if we look at a
meta-analysis of 27 placebo trials lfts
increased by with a risk ratio of 1.5
about a 9% increased risk of diabetes in
myalgia while you might say they aren't
that high in clinical practice this
often leads to interruption of statin
therapy or reduction of dose and the
fact that we look at some observational
studies myopathy symptoms have been
reported as high as 10% in a study of a
hundred thousand patients in two
academic medical centers about 50% of
patients at least had temporary
discontinuation of the statins about 17%
have adverse events leading to stoppage
of statins in about 11 percent of these
patients and only about half of them at
12 months were back on statins so there
are many reasons that patients may not
be on statins or on less than adequate
doses the guidelines do say we should
whenever possible
titrate to the maximally tolerated
intensity of dose based on their risk
category but in those that are still in
a high-risk group are on maximally
tolerated statin with a less than
anticipated response and there is some
question about how to define that but in
our patients here in this example had a
less than 50% reduction and was
compliant you may consider adding other
non statin therapies and particularly in
a high-risk group so patients with
clinically evident disease with familial
hypercholesterolemia and/or diabetes and
likewise in candidates for statin
therapy that are totally or partially
statin intolerant
they say it's reasonable to use non
statin therapies that have been shown to
reduce events whenever possible so there
are openings to treat the
individuals as well in the guidelines
now just briefly to point out that there
are other guidelines that are
contemporary that don't necessarily
agree with them the National lipid
Association guidelines still use simple
categories to divide patients into risk
but they also offer specific LDL but
also emphasize non HDL targets to treat
total a thorough genic lipoproteins so
in the high-risk patients they are still
asking for goals of therapy to less than
70 and 100 respectively in the European
guidelines again they have similar risk
categories to the accha guidelines but
they recommend targets of less than 70
and if not achievable at least a 50%
reduction in high-risk patients but also
still emphasize targets for LDL
reduction in the diabetes world the
American Diabetes Association which used
to have much more rigid goals for
therapy this year have followed along
with the recommendations of the ACCA H a
recommending higher moderate intensity
based on the diabetic sub risk so most
of these patients with any risk factors
or avert CBD being candidates for
high-intensity statin therapies and have
pulled away from previous guidelines
which recommended specific targets for
triglycerides and HDL Xand men and women
conversely Hayes though has continued to
recommend goals and in fact offers
multiple secondary goals so high-risk
individuals so this is a diabetic with
overt disease or one or more
cardiovascular risk factors they're
still calling for gold treatment to an
LDL less than 109 HDLs I mean 79 HDLs
than 100 triglycerides under 150 total
HDL ratios of less than three and
secondary goals of an April B which left
out here to be less than 80 in the
high-risk group an LDL particle number
added as a secondary goal of less than
1000 just a brief word about children
and adolescents although
in the specific guidelines if we try to
put together recommendations from the
National lipid Association the American
Academy of Pediatrics and expert panel
consensus statements from NHLBI they are
now calling for Universal screening of
children between the ages of nine to
eleven and then repeat screening after
20 years of age consider screening as
early as 2 years of age when there's a
strong family history of
hypercholesterolemia or family history
or the family history is unknown follow
more closely if LDL in a child is above
130 and non HDL above 145 and there are
now pushes for earlier pharmacologic
therapy and children over eight years of
age primarily with statins with an LDL
greater than 190 greater than 160 with
one or more risk factors and that
includes being overweight or obese or
greater than 130 in diabetes the
guidelines did recognize many potential
shortfalls and they this is just a list
of some of the clinical questions that
they've outlined to be addressed for
future guidelines and the type of
randomized clinical trials but I think
it's important that there is an emphasis
on understanding how to manage
hypertriglyceridemia and the use of non
HDL cholesterol and decision-making as
well as other other markers and trying
to address better the safety and
benefits in the elderly population so in
summary the main points of the
guidelines are here there's a shift away
from treating to certain goals and to
identify subgroups of patients that fall
into risk groups in which there's strong
evidence that treating with moderate to
high intensity statins substantially
reduce cardiovascular events statins
remain and are REM ffice eyes of the
first line of therapy for risk reduction
and we should try to titrate to the
maximally tolerated statin intensity for
their risk group lipid panels are
obtained in risk assessment and to
moderate inherence but not to identify
treatment to specific LDL or non HDL
goals in the
primary prevention population of
patients a new risk calculator has been
offered which has like many risk
calculators it's its own sets of
limitations but it's important to
remember that these are there to
identify potential risk in patients and
as a trigger to begin clinical patient
discussions not only to guide statin
therapy but also to be more aggressive
with encouraging lifestyle intervention
and risk factor control and although
there was some concern that patients
falling outside of the four categories
may not be treated and that there's no
role for non statin therapies there are
pathways in the guidelines in selected
individuals where non statin therapies
may have a role in managing these
patients but still there's little
guidance for the evaluation of patients
with hypertriglyceridemia and elevated
non HDL cholesterol so the agency
guidelines when we think about them are
not that much different in some of the
key principles of many guidelines that
are out there they encourage healthy
lifestyle patient discussion with
initiating therapy statins of the first
line of therapy appropriate intensity in
this case based on percent reduction REM
ffice izing that statins have an
acceptable margin of safety when use and
properly selected patients and that
these patients need to be regularly
monitored in terms of their adherence to
both drug and lifestyle changes and that
there is a place for non statin
therapies although it's downgraded
somewhat I think there's still some
concerns about the pooled cohort
equations and I think there are
limitations but there are limitations
that are also existed with other
calculators that we have used but I
think it does emphasize the need to
discuss thoroughly with patients to use
other risk markers and potentially some
other imaging techniques for assessment
of pre clinical disease to try and some
of these patients on the fence make a
decision about further treatment however
I think the goals therapy issues is
something that's going to be coming up
again now in light of the improve at
trial and future clinical trials so I
know we don't have too much time but I'd
be happy to address any questions that
you might have at this time and thank
you for your attention thank you Michael
for bringing that information to us in
your presentation time for Q&A you have
a question you'd like to ask dr. Rocco
please do so now
click on the green Q&A button at the
lower left of the presentation window
type your question into the box and
we'll get to as many of them as we can
our first question what is the
recommended approach to managing a
patient with intolerance to statins
so this is actually addressed in the
guidelines and it's based on an expert
opinion we recognize that there are
patients that cannot tolerate statins
the most common reason is because of
muscle symptoms or myalgias we also
recognize sometimes it's very hard to
sort out whether this is an association
or causality but in the bot the bottom
line is that patients may not be taking
the drugs or getting the benefits we
have found that not all statins are the
same and that patients who have a
problem with one statin may actually be
able to tolerate a different statins so
we will often target patients with two
or more statins often beginning at low
doses with slow titration the data with
coenzyme q-10 is somewhat conflicting
but at least we have seen some patients
that have benefited from coke q10
empirically so we will sometimes use
that at 200 milligrams a day so our main
approach is time with the patients don't
give up and try to constantly work with
the patients to try to get them on some
statins and it's in a study of over
1,800 patients that were referred to us
at the Cleveland Clinic with statin
intolerance predominantly with muscle
symptoms about 70% of those patients
were able to be maintained on some
statin regimen with about a 30%
reduction of LDL cholesterol so maybe
not ideal but something and a baseline
for then considering additions of other
therapies thank you our next question in
light of the aim high and thrive trials
are there still situations in which you
would use niacin yeah so they both the
aim high in the night and the thrive
trials looked at a group of patients
that were on statin therapy that were
well controlled and the LDL cholesterol
in those two trials at entry were
between 60 and 70 triglycerides were not
that elevated in either of these trials
so in the total population there was not
a benefit however in a sub analysis of
the aim trial as I said one of the
slides earlier
patients with high triglycerides and low
HDL did seem to benefit and in a sub
analysis of the Thrive trial individuals
with the highest turtle of LDL
cholesterol zhan entries seemed to
benefit as well so I think there is some
evidence from subgroup analysis that in
patients that are on statin therapy that
either are not at adequate goals meaning
in LDL cholesterol still above 70 or
they have persistent elevations in
triglycerides in low HDL that additions
of niacin may have some benefits so I do
use niacin in that population of
patients the other population of
individuals that are statin intolerant
or partially statin intolerance we think
of niacin as an HDL raising drug but at
high doses up to 2,000 milligrams you
can see about a 15 to 20 percent
reduction in LDL cholesterol and niacin
was one of the pre statin error drugs
that had been shown in the coronary drug
project to benefit patients after
myocardial infarction and preventing
recurrent myocardial infarction so I
will often use niacin at higher doses if
tolerated as part of a combination
strategy and patients that are
completely or partially statin
intolerant thank you our next question
from our audience member
any comments on patient adherence PSC
canine subcutaneous injections yeah so
we have been involved in a number of the
some pcsk9 trials and that was a concern
upfront because it is a self injection
the truth is we've had virtually no
pushback in from the patients that have
been in our clinical trials in terms of
the injections both of the drugs that
are available now have self injections
pens so they're easy for patients to use
there can be some local skin reactions
but the seems to be much lower than
initially anticipated so I found that
that our patients are tolerating it well
they're not having problems with
self-injection and I haven't gotten a
lot of pushback great thank you for that
answer we have another question from an
audience member would it be lowest
dosage of statin that can be given well
you can give any any goes you like I
guess but but it's recommended that you
give a dose of a statin that can lower
LDL cholesterol at least 30% if possible
so any any of the dose ranges of receive
a statin and atorvastatin would meet
that 40 to 80 milligrams of simvastatin
80 milligrams of pravastatin for example
our drugs that would meet that criteria
you know and that's based on the
clinical trials that have been done and
most of the trials that have been done
in the past have used those doses of
drugs or higher to achieve 30 to 50
percent or more reductions so that's
where that that comes from but sometimes
we use lower doses because they can't
tolerate higher doses and that's a
situation where we would often consider
using other therapies like nice and
Rosetta might in combination in the
high-risk patient group okay thank you
for that we are almost out of time but
we do have time for one last question
any comments on PFC k9 inhibitors along
with statins do we give a highest dose
or low dose yeah well I mean this is
something that's still evolving we do
know that whether you use a pcsk9 as
mono therapy or in addition to statins
it has the same effect about a 50%
reduction in LDL cholesterol the problem
is we don't have the outcome data at the
moment so and most of the pcsk9 drugs
have very little in terms of titration
so if you're going to add a pcsk9 with a
LaRocca map you can titrate from 75 to
150 but you're still going to see
relative high reductions in LDL
cholesterol and with Eva loca
it's a single-dose so I think the more
important question is when you started
in patients that are on sentence so
should all patients that have LDL
cholesterol zuv 80 or 90 in a high-risk
group that are on maximally tolerated
statins we placed it on this drug I
think at the moment we know it'll lower
the cholesterol another 50% but we don't
really have a lot of good outcome data I
think I tend to be at the moment leaning
toward those individuals that are very
high-risk that have LDL cholesterol that
are above 100 or patients that we still
have high LDL cholesterol that our
statin intolerant patients that have had
recurrent events despite being on
adequate statin therapy and individuals
with familial hypercholesterolemia we're
even on maximal statins LDL cholesterol
are still high even a primary care
population but I think this is going to
be sorted out
more over time as the long term outcome
trials are done I mean there's also the
controversy at the other end can we get
too low with LDL cholesterol so far in
these trials we haven't seen a strong
signal that very low LDL cholesterol are
associated with a higher incidence of
adverse events but we'll have a lot more
information from the the long randomized
trials great thank you that is all the
time we have for our questions I'd like
to thank Michael Rocco once again for
his presentation and just ask him if he
has any final comments to leave our
audience with no I I thank you for being
here and listening I think the important
thing to remember with guidelines is
that they're just that they're
guidelines they're not rules
we can apply these to our individual
patients but we always have to look at
the patient as an individual and make
the best decision for that individual
patient these guidelines are just there
to aid us in starting these
conversations and discussing the
appropriate therapies super thank you
again dr. Rocca for being here
I also want to let our audience know
that today's webcast will be available
for on-demand viewing through May 2016
you'll receive an e
from lab roots letting you know when
this webcast is available for replay and
we would invite you to share that email
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event thank you again for
joining us here at laggards we hope to
see you again
goodbye